let me just ask you in the difference in
in the culture because you've reached
there's so many Rockets from so many
different eras the Saturn V and just
everything you're seeing now are there
some interesting differences especially
when you look at the space race between
um the Soviet
rocket engineers and efforts versus the
American
the others I mean there's definitely
huge huge cultural changes and the fun
thing is that they kind of spawned from
the same they have the same starting
Place both you know the Soviet rocket
engines and Americans all came from the
Nazi V2 rocket and the A4 engine
literally physically spawned from that
because at the fall of you know at the
end of World War II we took a handful of
German scientists and the Soviets took a
handful of German scientists and they
both got their own a little bit some
blueprints here and there and the others
got some blue so we literally have the
same it's a weird thing where we're
starting from the same like thing and
letting two uh two Divergent you know
Divergent paths go crazy on their own
development so it's really fun to see
the cultural differences one of the
things the United States did is they
really would kind of take an engine
and and just perfect it more or less and
then and not really evolve that much
like they they I don't know and I don't
know why I actually need to do a history
lesson on all of the U.S engines but
it's literally like uh as far as orbital
class engines before now
and it's like a dozen or two you know
it's it's it's a tenth the amount of the
Soviets and the Soviets just literally
made up a new engine every time they had
a new like they went uh and it was like
a completely different engine yeah so I
just yeah I wonder if there's some
aspect to the culture and I don't want
to overstate it but uh there is more of
a safety culture I think in the United
States and I think if you care about
safety or rather like you have
uh you're more risk-averse yeah so you
care about safety more about the value
of human life than there is taken there
that you will iterate less so yeah I
think the Soviets especially in the
early aspect of the program I don't want
to overstate this is
um some of it is just
um through stories you just hey are
anecdotes there are more willing to take
risks yeah risks with human life risks
with spacecraft for example the first uh
orbital space flights from the Soviet
Union the the Cosmonaut had to eject out
of the capsule and parachute to a
landing yes that's not very well like
known and it wasn't they hid that even
from history as best they could at first
because they were slightly ashamed that
they couldn't have a full recovery
system with their spacecraft they could
physically recover it but they wouldn't
have been able to recover the cosmonaut
in one piece so instead they had them
just eject out of the thing and
parachute to safety like that's insane
and so there definitely was some some
extra risks and but all also a freedom
to just like push things to the limits
and try everything you know they threw
EV all the spaghetti on the wall